romain mi-journée les spécialistes du
venezuela bonsoir romain miguet merci
d'être avec nous alors ce partenariat
caracas theron peut-on parler d'une
réussite diplomatique
est ce une première sur le pétrole alors
sans aucun doute déjà merci pour
l'invitation sans aucun doute je
voudrais quand même revenir sur un
détail qui m'a frappé dans votre petit
reportage introductif
il s'agit d'une vente d'essence n'est ce
pas je crois que c'est
c'est fondamental de comprendre ça
puisque le venezuela effectivement des
grandes réserves de pétrole mais c'est
un pétrole extra-lourd et pour le
transformer en essence il faut de
nombreux additifs
il faut le raffiné il faut de nombreux
additifs et c'est précisément cela qui
manquait au venezuela
puisque le venezuela je crois qu'il est
important de le rappeler aussi et subit
un blocus criminel de la part des
etats-unis et de leur salle de ses
satellites et donc qui empêche le
venezuela de s'approvisionner en
additifs en aftam notamment et de
d'utiliser des pièces de rechange dont
la chaîne industrielle est très liée
historiquement aux services pétroliers
étasunien je rappelle aussi que sept
raffineries vénézuéliennes sur le sol
des états unis ont été purement et
simplement volé donc le la pénurie
d'essence au venezuela ne n'est pas d'un
un bain de rien on va dire elle est
évidemment un trait segments liés au
blocus des états unis et donc c'est
téhéran depuis avril a envoyé des
ingénieurs et des pièces de rechange
pour faire repartir les raffineries
vénézuéliennes et aujourd'hui dont 5
tankers avec 1,5 million de barils
d'essence pour faire repartir les
raffineries
alors c'est vrai que quand on écoute
votre analyse qui est très clair aux
comprend davantage l'intérêt majeur de
venezuela dans cette opération
oui du venezuela et de l'iran aussi
puisque je rappelle aussi que l'iran
subit lui aussi un blocus criminel de la
part des mêmes personnes qui asphyxie le
peuple vénézuélien c'est à dire le
gouvernement des états unis et ses
satellites est alors au delà du coût
diplomatique puisque je crois c'est très
important de souligner que ce n'est pas
une alliance du venezuela avec une méga
puissances comme la chine ou la russie
il s'agit d'une puissance moyenne
intermédiaires comme l'iran et le
venezuela c'est une alliance qui
s'inscrit dans la coopération sud-sud
que le président ancien président hugo
chavez avait établi avec son homologue
de l'époque mahmoud ahmadinedjad
c'est évidemment un coût diplomatique
parce que c'est un défi à au blocus et
aux sanctions des états unis et je crois
qu'il est important de souligner
l'aspect solidaire
parce que figurez-vous que l'iran a lui
aussi de sérieux problèmes dus au blocus
l'iran a dû resserrer le budget de son
état à 40 milliards de dollars c'est le
budget le plus restreint depuis la fin
de la guerre iran irak et depuis
novembre 2019 le l'essence à la pompe
pour les citoyens iraniens est rationné
à 60 litres par mois et par voiture
donc c'est un geste aussi de solidarité
et de coopération sud sud qui a son
importance
aujourd'hui au venezuela alors on
comprend que les etats unis doivent être
contrarié
qu'est ce que risquent ces pays
notamment l'iran de nouvelles sanctions
et écouter les cinq bateaux donc le
clavel le fortune leforest et le pétunia
sont déjà tous sous sanctions des
etats-unis non le venezuela tout son
industrie pétrolière est sous sanctions
des etats-unis à dire que si vous
vouliez vous par exemple faire des
échanges commerciaux avec l'industrie
pétrolière vénézuélienne vous même
madame ou mademoiselle vous tomberiez
sous le coup des sanctions des
etats-unis
je rappelle que le charger amérique
latine du conseil national de sécurité
des états unis a il y a cinq jours
menacé des compagnies pétrolières
notamment indienne et européenne de
sanctions destructrice si elle se
laissait aller à des échanges
commerciaux avec le venezuela l'iran et
sanctionner le venezuela est sanctionné
donc je dirais dans un sens qui ne le
peuvent pas pas plus à perdre et au
contraire c'est cette alliance justement
entre bateaux sanctionné et gouvernement
sanctionné qui vient mettre un grain de
sable dans la stratégie des etats-unis
contre ces deux pays est ce que ça peut
ouvrir la porte à d'autres partenariats
et dans quels domaines alors ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que le ce n'est pas le
premier partenariat de l'iran avec le
venezuela
il y a eu des partenariats dans
l'agriculture il ya eu des partenariats
dans l'industrie l'iran avait établi des
djeun devanture il ya de cela quelques
années pour la fabrication de tracteurs
et de voitures au venezuela
c'était une une voie qu'a ouvert hugo
chavez pour diversifier on va dire les
clients de son industrie pétrolière et
puis surtout avec une vision d'un monde
multipolaire qui ne s'ancre pas sur les
desseins de washington donc
effectivement cela peut ouvrir la voie à
l'approfondissement
deux pays qui sont je le répète sous le
coup de blocus criminel qui asphyxient
leur population merci romain mag journée
spécialiste du venezuela pour ses
explications